thank you
[Music]
hello and welcome to our favorite
program I'd like to know I am in the
company of Pastor Daniel Miranda and
Pastor good to be with you as always
good to be with you as well this is our
fun program we we love this program
because it gives us the opportunity to
study the word of God to hear the
questions that are coming from you and
it gives us a sense of what is happening
in the church and in the world and those
kinds of things that um are troubling
you the things that people are
discussing uh and uh the questions that
they have the issues that uh in these
last days uh pertain to the finishing of
the work men and women trying to walk
with God and serve in the best they can
questions come up and they need to be
answered and so we as always make you
the promise that if there is an answer
that can be found from the word of God
we will find that answer and we will
answer it from the word of God
as best we can again we beg your
patience and Indulgence because the list
is getting long a number of things that
says to us one that the show is popular
too that you trust us with your
questions and three a lot of people are
watching and sending in questions well
the consequence of that is that
sometimes we get a little backed up with
questions and and backed up maybe an
understatement because the questions are
are coming in at a fairly good clip and
our pile is getting long but that's good
for us that's something we we like to do
so if you don't hear here the answer to
your question quite as soon as you would
like then I encourage you stay with us
we'll get to it we make you that promise
we don't throw any questions away we
don't toss anything out no question is
foolish we have some people who say
sometimes well my question seems kind of
silly no if it is of concern to you it
is of concern to us and we want to
answer your question so send your
questions into TV at some tv.org that is
TV at some tv.org and we will get to
them just as soon as we can I am going
to uh offer a prayer this time and then
Daniel since you've had a little second
uh longer to look at this question and
it there's many facets to it I'm going
to sort of put this one in your hands
and let you sort of win your way through
it as together we try to answer these
questions from from our viewer
father God again we praise you and thank
you so very much for the privilege of
studying the word of God Amen we are
thankful that the word of God was
written to be studied yes to be
understood to be put into practice and
Lord we pray that as we find these
answers uh you will give us the strength
the wisdom to know how to do it and the
strength to accomplish those things that
we know to be right because it is in the
doing that we are made like Christ Jesus
and we know that righteousness is right
doing yes so bless us dear father we do
pray during this program and each and
every program of this nature in Jesus
name we thank you amen and amen amen
praise the Lord
okay this question comes from I believe
is Oliver
and has a nickname who is that guy and
the question has to do with the Seal of
God
there is actually several questions here
in one question number one has several
parts it says do you notice that the
Holy Spirit sealed and the Sabbath as a
Zeal have been controversy that's how it
is written has have been controversy or
controversial among
the people who come to believe the 28
fundamental beliefs of The Seventh-Day
Adventist Church
based entirely on Bible verse
so and then on this question he has
three issues that he wants to resolve
one is that in a sense of discrediting
the Holy Spirit as the solar sealer
number two that is a seal is obtained
fully from the Old Testament in a
statement in Exodus and number three it
seems that members are following the
leading of what the church wants as a
fitting interpretation for fit their
name title seventh day so in other words
the issue here is whether the Sabbath is
really the seal and not the Holy Spirit
and then the question continues
it says as for me what I believe is that
the holy spirit is what converts a
person and works on changing a person
let's say I get converted to follow the
Messiah while in the Seventh Day
Adventist Church Yahweh Works in me to
change me into a new person's grace
through his holy spirit then I start to
have the fruits of the Holy Spirit but
while in the church I adopt the belief
that the Sabbath has features of a seal
even explained in the Old Testament so I
have the character of Christ through the
transformation then I have believe the
Sabbath
acts as a seal
and then he calls Ephesians chapter 4
verse 30 that is a is a quote
or is a verse that is often used
to counteract or to counter the Sabbath
seal
many non-advanists feel like
like from my background I heard them
share that the character of God is the
same as the name of the father on the
forehead now people who also understand
character and holy spirit to be only
signs and seals
I wonder why the Sabbath is added to the
picture
so let me put this in order because
there are lots of thoughts at that point
lots of points here that he's bringing
so basically what I understand and I
hope I understood correctly is that our
brother Oliver is trying to reconcile
the fact that the Bible teaches
in both the Old and the New Testament
that the Holy Spirit especially in the
New Testament like Ephesians 4 4 30 that
the holy spirit is the one that seals
but we are Seventh-day Adventists we say
that the Seal of God is the Sabbath
so how can we reconcile those two ideas
are we forcing the scriptures to say
that the Sabbath is the seal to kind of
fit in the seventh day as he said so
that that's the bottom line of question
one and question two is why not leave it
there and not add an identifying Mark of
the church okay a couple of things um
he referred to Ephesians 4 30 and that's
I had not read all of this and I went
initially to 4 30 because
um and we'll just read that very quickly
do not grieve the holy spirit of God by
whom ye were sealed for the day of
redemption
so we we find from this text and from
others that the active ceiling agent is
that
agency by which the mind of Christ is
brought into us by which we receive the
Mount of Christ that seals us is the
spirit of God
um so he's correct in that now the other
part of his thing is is his question
seems to be that we are adding to that
by saying the the Sabbath also seals
um I think that's what he's saying
because there are a lot of products to
that
um
what I would say about the Sabbath is
that the Sabbath is a sign now God
identifies himself in the Sabbath he
without this the Sabbath commandment we
wouldn't even really know who wrote the
Ten Commandments because God identifies
himself in that it is a special sign
that we are sealed it is a a an emblem
that we're walking with God and that we
believe in all that he says we see that
from Exodus
um 31.
um but it is not the ceiling agent
um it it is a sign that we are sealed
but it is not the agency yes by which we
are sealed and I think that's where he
he thinks the churches is but I don't
see the church as as doing that I don't
see that Adventist Church is saying that
the Sabbath is going to seal you
um it may be a sign that you are sealed
it may be a sign that you're settled
into the truth but it is not the ceiling
agent that is the work of the holy
spirit that is correct and and let me
reinforce your answer which I believe is
the answer is biblical there is biblical
evidence for where you for for what you
just said
now our brother here is is right
in saying that it there seems to be a
contradiction and I emphasize there
seems to be seems to be but there is not
a contradiction uh actually in in
Spanish and I think it also works uh in
English we have the same word seal for
both the the tool that you use to seal
yes the instrument yes and for the mark
or the imprint that is left on the paper
so we call both seal in Spanish Sergio
yes both the the you know the stamp and
also the mark that is left yeah when you
go to another Republic notary public he
will press that thing down on your paper
the thing that you see on the paper is
the seal it is done with a seal exactly
it's the same way it's the same in
English Okay so the Bible
uses it also in the same way yes now
seventh day Adventists and and and we
should we wouldn't say that Adventists
are forcing the Sabbath to say that it
is a seal because even actually Ellen
White recognized it as so now she was
not the first one that said it we got to
be clear with that the first one that uh
brought this view to us was Joseph Bates
in in the work uh the The Seventh-Day
Sabbath a Perpetual sign correct in that
first publication from Joseph Bates we
find that the Sabbath as the seal so he
gave he went beyond the Baptists uh to
to say that the seventh day was only a
day for rest but he gave the Sabbath's
catological Dimension yes for the last
days as a seal of God now Ellen y agrees
with Joseph Bates Joseph Bates and here
in Patriots and Prophets page 307 she
says the fourth Commandment is the only
one of all all
the fourth Commandment is the only one
of all the ten in which are found both
the name and the title of the law Giver
right it is the only one that shows by
whose authority the law is given thus it
contains the seal notice it doesn't it's
not the one that seals but it contains
the seal
of God
affixed to his law as evidence of its
authenticity and binding Force yes she
also says in signs of the times November
1899 the Sabbath of the fourth
Commandment is the Seal of the Living
God it identifies God as the Creator and
it is the sign of his righteous
authority over
all his created beings yes that's what I
was alluding to but talking about the
the second use of the word seal one is
to seal is to is to well what's the word
I wanted to sort of encapsulate and and
to to put a cocoon around the other is
the the the the the
emblem that's in your forehead that is
that says that you are settled in the
the truth of God and that's what Ellen
White is referring to it's correct not
that it the Sabbath is the ceiling agent
but it is the seal yes of God Amen and
not only on the other hand not only
Ephesians 4 verse 30 but also Ephesians
chapter 1 verses 13 and 14. yes you're
going to read it if you have it there
yeah um alludes alludes to the Holy
Spirit
indeed and we'll give it we'll bring a
balance here and a connection between
these two concepts I'm picking up at
verse 13 chapter one of the book of
Ephesians in him
you also trusted after you heard the
word of Truth The Gospel of your
salvation in whom also having believed
you were sealed with the spirit of
Promise who is the guarantee of our
inheritance until the Redemption of the
purchased possession to the praise of
his glory so again the one that seals
here is the holy spirit just one more
text I'm going to read this one second
Corinthians chapter 1 21 and 22 Second
Corinthians chapter 1 verses 21 and 22
the Bible says now he who establishes us
with you in Christ and has anointed us
is God
who also has sealed us and given us the
spirit in our hearts as a guarantee
so how do we reconcile that well the
Holy Spirit as you said is the ceiling
agent the Sabbath is the external sign
that we are sealed yes yes and we have
we have two examples in the Bible for
example circumcision
circumcision
was given the the the main purpose of
was not the the flesh it was not the the
foreskin right circumcision had a
purpose of teaching
the Israelites about the work of the of
conversion that the Lord wanted to
accomplish in their hearts actually
Deuteronomy 30 verse 6 it says that the
Lord will circumcise your hearts so
circumcision of the flesh was only
external evidence of a work that God had
accomplished in their hearts same thing
with baptism yes we believe baptism the
right of baptism is only external sign
of the work of the holy spirit in our
hearts same thing with the Sabbath there
this ver this term seal has a verbal
sense and a noun sense that's right uh
and sometimes it's used as a noun in a
noun noun can we use that as a word now
no sense and other in a verbal sense or
the uh as a verb uh one it is something
that is is being done the other is
something that is done
um and um so they're not antagonistic to
each other in fact they are
complementary amen
so and then in question number two he
says why not leave it there and not add
an identifying Mark of the church in
other words why why to go why to add the
Sabbath as an identifying Mark of the
church and not leave it there
because God does exactly
God says it's a sign and will be
assigned and will continue to be a sign
and it's a very distinguishable sign uh
that we are in the Lord uh and that we
are following all of the will of God so
we we make it special because God makes
it special yes and we don't do anything
with the Sabbath that is not uh
authorized uh by God Amen yeah first of
all is in the Bible yes secondly our
Pioneers recognize it and thirdly Ellen
White agrees with that she speaks of the
of the all landmarks which includes the
law and the Sabbath and the Sabbath as
part of our landmarks
okay very good good question and thank
you um uh Oliver uh who is that guy
that's an interesting sort of handle uh
but a lot there but uh thank you and
hopefully we did Justice to your
question
this one comes from Isaac niambia
um and concerns the rich man and Lazarus
we get questions on him every now and
again and thank you for writing to us
from Zimbabwe we are uh privileged to be
on in that country and thank you for
taking the time let's see thank you
Pastor Bohr Rafferty Miranda uh
AC I guess in NCAA
I've been called cacd AC
it's quite all right
for your program I would like to know
um it's really relaxed and laid back way
of learning the Bible yet serious at the
same time uh a wonderful balance thank
you
um Isaac my question is on the parable
of the rich man and Lazarus what is the
Lord trying to teach us in this story
which seems to contradict the whole
doctrine of the state of the dead of
course it does yes
that's the well anyway
additionally can you also address the
following verse with regards to Abel
um Genesis 4 10. well let's let's deal
with the with the richness Lazarus yes
and um then we'll we'll come back
because we don't want to sort of cross
fertilize the two
um
talking about the the parable of Lazarus
a couple of things I want to start and
give some general
um Council when dealing with parables
you cannot translate every aspect of a
parable yes to the real life situations
parables are given as examples uh and
each Parable has a specific goal or
specific teaching that it is trying to
to address so they're not perfect
representations many times parables are
given because of the understanding of
the people who were on the receiving end
of the parable so you don't want to try
to develop doctrinal premises from
Parables because they were not intended
to be used that way particularly the
rich man at Lazarus if
we take the parable uh
uh as stated heaven and hell are very
close to each other where one person can
reach over from one and touch the other
uh two uh we were taught and and as I
did my research that this pair was based
on a a an old story that the Jews knew
called the the rich men and barbation
um and Christ took that and out of that
he drew a lesson for the people who were
there but it was not intended to be
something that you develop doctrinal
premises from because if that were so
you'd have to say well heaven and hell
are really right next to each other
about as close as we're standing
together here sitting together here and
that was not the purpose of that and
another detail if we take it literally
then we would conclude that just a drop
of water is enough to quench the third
The Thirst in burning hell which
not even here in summertime in Fresno no
one drop of water is not going to be any
good if you can even get it up to your
tongue because it would evaporate so
fast that's right so the fact that it's
a parable uh it is not used for
doctrinal premises so it's not that it
invades against uh the true biblical
understanding of the state of the dead
it's not to be used for uh an
understanding of the state of the Dead
Christ had a different purpose or rather
Bible teachers had a different purpose
in using that Parable
and it was not to establish the stated
Edition now pastor Murray some people
question what you just said that this is
actually a parable and they reason that
this is actually a true story that Jesus
is telling because
it doesn't follow according to them yes
the format of a parable of a parable and
also is the only Parable that includes
the name of a person in this case
Lazarus any thoughts on that
um
I I have heard that but again it was
based on the understanding of of the
people and it was based on the
understanding that if you live well in
this life you will live bad in the life
of God yes that um the Jews believe that
so Christ took that belief uh as errand
as it was and used that to teach a
lesson and also you know even the
terrible before actually Jesus is here
telling a train of Parables and that for
example the parable of the unjust
Steward in Luke 16 verse 1 begins with
the same format uh it doesn't say the
Kingdom of Heaven is like unto this no
you're right but it's it goes right to
the point there was a certain rich man
who had a steward and an accusation was
brought to him that this man was wasting
his Goods so very simple follows the
same format and the reason why this
mentions Lazarus is because actually
Jesus in the parable is also telling a
prophecy and this is a exactly what
happened to Lazarus when Jesus
resurrected him they did not even
believe that that that Lazarus had been
resurrected or they did not believe in
Jesus
so Jesus says As you said Jesus's main
point in this Parable is not to teach
about the state of the Dead
actually I believe
um
the main point or the main teaching of
this Parable is found in Verses 25 and
26 of Luke 16. Luke 16 verses 25 and 26
I'm going to read from the new King
James version the Bible says and Abraham
said Son remember that in your lifetime
you received your good things and
likewise Lazaro's evil things but now he
is comforted and you are tormented
and besides all these between Acts
and between us and new there is a great
golf fixed so that those who want to
pass from here to you cannot nor can
those from there to pass to us so what
is Jesus actually saying that it is in
our lifetime when our destiny is fixed
when death comes we cannot reverse yes
the things that we have done in life yes
and also basically the main teaching
very true and also the fact that that
worldly wealth does not guarantee us
anything in the Kingdom that's another
it has nothing it has no no value uh
only what you do for the Lord but your
money is not going to help you in uh in
the next life because
um it's not it's not valued there and uh
is not is not is not important so there
are many many lessons that come from
this Parable but it is never to be used
never to be thought of as something that
teaches a a lesson as far as the state
of the Dead is concerned and was not to
be used for that purpose and Jesus
Twisted the meaning purposely because
the Jews believed here the rich
represents the Jews the Pharisees and
they were the ones that believed that
they call Abraham father yes and they
were the ones that believed that they
had salvation assured in the bosom of
Abraham I actually believe in the
immortality of the Soul as well yes but
now Jesus changes
the the the the
you know the perspective and now he
shows actually Lazarus that he
representing the Gentiles who are eating
from the crimes that fall from the table
actually they have an easier access to
the bosom of Abraham they are the true
children of Abraham those who are
faithful than those who have lied but
ayat did not use that light while they
were living while they did not bless
Humanity with the riches they thought
that they were rich and increasing Goods
very much so but they were poor and
miserable as Jesus says yeah did you
read verse 25 from this this verse 25
Luke 16 25 yes okay okay because I'm
just my mind is scanning over again and
it really kind of explains that uh you
know because you were Rich you thought
that you were going to be fine and then
Here Comes This likewise Lazarus evil
things but now he is confident you are
tormented uh so Christ could have sort
of flips their idea on its on its head
that uh just because you're rich and uh
you have the knowledge you have the
history and you you have Abraham as your
father does not guarantee to guarantee
you anything uh in the long run
alrighty we are down to our last two two
uh minutes and I don't want to just dive
into another question because we'd have
to sort of Dash through it
um any closing thoughts down to before
we wrap up yes one more Point here when
this Parable is that I draw a third
lesson
n is the answer of Abraham to to the
rich man when he says well please send
Lazarus to go and preach to my five
Brethren and he says no they have the
scriptures
um they should believe the prophets
Moses and the prophets because if they
do not believe Moses and the prophets
neither will they be persuaded though
one rise from the dead in other words
yes our faith should not depend on
Miracles but should depend on the word
of God the word of God has more power
and more evidence than the Miracles that
we can see amen and I think that's a
very good and solid point that we we've
got the word of God you know
um that's the burden for the gospel
that's written by John John wrote very
very late John wrote to to John the
Revelator John wrote so late that most
of the people who had seen Christ and
known Christ uh were gone he wrote to
that next Generation who whose only
connection with Christ was the word that
Christ left but his point is if you have
the word it's as good as having him here
amen you know you don't lose anything
because you're the Next Generation Well
that is meat for us too at the end of
time we don't have Christ and I wish
sometimes I I had Christ when I say you
know what's going on what's happening
but I don't but I do have his word amen
and he has invested in his word and it's
like having Christ here uh it's an
important point from the gospel as
written by John throughout all of John's
writing writings again
our time has fast slipped into
eternity allow me in closing to wish you
both Grace and peace through our Lord
and Savior Jesus Christ we'll see you
again soon bye bye and may God richly
bless you
[Music]
thank you